before we let's pray again loving
father in heaven come among us
very closely their god because
the devil is trying to confuse us
let your spirit clarify our thinking and teach
us their god in jesus name i pray amen yes
romans 7 verses 14 to 24. the natural the natural
man without christ now many are of the contention
that he's talking about himself after his
conversion and um can you shed some light on that
because there's a lot of mis misunderstandings
concerning that particular passage of scripture
all right let's read a few read a few verses
let's read from 14 to 18 just give a sample
of what we're dealing with okay romans
chapter 7 verse 3 from 12 to 4 okay 18.
all right it says wherefore the law is holy
and the commandment holy and just and good
was then that which is good made death unto me
god forbid okay false false was that which is good
made death unto me what does it mean by that
which is good what is that that's good the law
the law yes was that which is good made death
unto me because the law condemns to death those
who break it so paul is saying was that thing an
instrument of death keep reading god forbid god
forbid the law was if you read verse 10 here's
how what the law was given for read verse then
and the commandment which was ordained which was
ordained to lie yes the purpose of the law is life
i found because sin entered then condemnation
came but the purpose of the law is life
who has uh great controversy anyone go
to page 467 read paragraph four listen
carefully my brother i'll come back to you
this may be the only question we answer we
have so many things to say great controversy
i hope that paging system is the same 467
paragraph four the law reveals to man his
sins but provides no remedy do you have that
oh not in this one oh who wrote that
one it's not that the one by ella white
okay okay all right well let's just go here's
what it says the law reveals to man his sins
but provides no remedy listen carefully now while
it promises life to the obedient it declares that
death is the portion of the did somebody find
it on the computer back there yes oh who has
it great controversy oh read it for us now make
sure i've already said it oh okay say it again
the law reveals to man go on uh-huh but it
provides no remedy listen careful enough while
it promises life to the obedience it declares
that death it promises life to the obedience
but death to the transgressor now so when paul
says was that which is good made death to me
there's nothing wrong with
the law the problem is us
are you calling so the law is holy just and good
we read that in 12. keep reading my brother 13.
okay continue in verse 13 but sin that it might
appear sin working death in me by that which is
good that sin by the commandment might become
exceedingly sinful listen to that verse again
read 13 again because then that which is good
made death unto me which is uh the law of force
was good was it death unto me the law wasn't made
for death but we die because we break the law keep
reading god forbid but sin that it might appear
sin stop did you catch what that thing is saying
now that sin that it might appear
sin meaning that sin does not always
look like sin it does not always look like sin
are you following me so the bible says how then do
you expose sin for what it is because it does not
look like sin we go back to eden for god does know
in the day either of then what your eyes shall
be opened you should be as gods it doesn't look
like sin this looks like benefits and so the
bible said that but sin that it might appear
sin we need our eyes open and the only thing
that opens the eyes is the word of god and
the part of the word of god that opens the eyes
more than anything else is the ten commandments
you know as i said of the entire
bible nothing opens the mind
the eye to what is saying
like the ten commandments
but sin that it might appear sin keep reading
working death in me by that which is good
the law makes sin appear as it
really is exceeding sinful any sin
we are we have little sins we have big sins the
bible says the law of god makes sin appear for
what it really is exceeding sinful verse 14 for
we know that the law is spiritual but i am carnal
soul under sin now he opposes carnal or spiritual
so everything spiritual then in that context
is good everything carnal is bad the law is
spiritual i am carnal meaning the problem is me
so he tells us the law is good the law is not
death the law is spiritual verse 10 he says the
laws of the into life you know he tells the
law is spiritual the law is holy the law is
just the law is good i am carnal so the problem
is me the carnal nature you see keep reading
for that which i do allow not for that which
i do i uh-huh god what i would that do i not
but what i hate that i read do i very
simple the things i should not do
i do and the things i should do which i recognize
is good i don't do the question is why is that
why is it that we realize this is
what i should do but i don't do it
this is what i shouldn't do but that's what
i do what accounts for that the carnal nature
the lord is spiritual law is holy the law is just
the law is good so everything the law asks us to
do is holy just spiritual and good but paul says
i am what carnal now paul isn't saying i am carnal
and everybody else is not no his his carnal nature
is the same as everybody else's so that statement
i am carnal simply means the world is carnal
you're carnal i am carnal she's carnal the carnal
nature stands in opposition to the law
that is spiritual holy just good and life
i am born opposed to that because he also
says in romans 8 4 7 because the carnal mind
is what enmity against god against everything
that is of god for it is not subject to the
law of god we read that clearly in chapter eight
it is not subject here we have a man who is not
subject to the law of god because of his nature
until of course god gives him a different nature
that nature now is in harmony with that
which is spiritual holy just good and life
with that new nature the man lives a life
that pleases god god doesn't get rid of the
old nature he gives in the new one that takes
control that sits on the throne of his life
the domination of the old nature is killed that is
what is crucified the rule of the carnal nature is
crucified the spiritual nature is that which
direct that man's life and so under the old
nature we may want to do what's right but we
cannot do it a desire for good is not enough
even the sinner knows i shouldn't kill i
shouldn't steal but i'm going to steal anyway
when the new nature comes in it comes with a
power that overrides the natural urge to do wrong
listen to me very clearly doing wrong is
the natural desire of an unregenerate heart
it is the you know elohim said
he was made captive by satan
i think that steps to christ pit 17 paragraph
one someone can find that he was made captive
by satan and would have remained so
forever had not god specially interposed
testimonies volume one page 341
paragraph one someone can check it
fallen man is satan's lawful captive
and so that man in romans 7 14 to 24 is
someone not unregenerate not yet changed
by the power of god by the spirit of god and
he he sees that's nice that's good can't do it
i shouldn't do that but i'm going to do it
conversion is what changes that christ is what
changes that the carnal nature has to be overcome
by the spiritual nature and the spiritual nature
comes in takes control from conversion and
in the walk called sanctification all right
anything else yes just to clarify paul then
is he talking about himself here people say oh
he's talking about himself after his conversion
after his conversion no no no no no no no no
the same way doing wrong comes naturally to the
unconverted man doing right comes naturally to the
converted person this is ellen white mind carton
personality volume 2 page 601 paragraph 4 someone
can check it listen carefully that which at first
seems difficult by constant repetition grows easy
and right thoughts and actions become habitual
in other words as sin is the
habit for the unconverted person
doing right becomes the natural behavior of a
converted person you see we have two natures
one nature produces sin the other produces
righteousness both produce them naturally
that's why jesus says a good tree cannot
divide bring forth evil fruit cannot do it
you're saying amen because you're good-looking and
nice but are you following me a good tree cannot
bring forth evil fruit neither
can a corrupt tree bring forth
good fruit there are two different natures
the person who says i'm converted and continues
to do what displeases god is not converted
all right next question thank you my good
brother blessings upon yes the mic is coming you